one of the extraordinary things about
the situation in shanghai is that in a
city of 25 million people which has
registered hundreds of thousands of
covert 19 affections there had been no
serious cases really and no deaths now
that sadly has changed over the weekend
china reporting three people had died of
covert 19 and on monday that seven
people had died of kovat19 so there are
fatalities now officially recorded by
china and despite that sad news though
it is a very very low rate for a city of
25 million people leading some to ask
why these really tough measures are in
place people are going into their fourth
week of lockdown it is a very strict
lockdown you're not allowed to leave
your house in many places or your
residential compound you've got to rely
on the government to deliver food
supplies and we saw problems with that
we've seen lots of tensions
between residents and the authority now
reuters had reported that shanghai
officials are hoping to try and
eliminate community spread of the virus
by as early as wednesday and that could
lead to some easing of restrictions but
i think the bigger answer here is half
scientific half political the scientific
side of it is that shanghai officials
say that only 38
of over 60s are vaccinated fully
vaccinated that is an extraordinary low
number that obviously prevents a huge
risk um to the city to those people who
aren't vaccinated but at the same time
we haven't really seen over the last
four weeks a huge drive to get those
people vaccinated i think that's where
the political side of this comes in the
head of china's national health
commission saying we should resolutely
oppose the wrongful thinking of
co-existence with kovid 19 and should
prepare for the party congress that's
coming up that's reference to a big
political event this autumn where we
expect xi jinping the president of china
will claim a third term as president
which is a departure from recent norms
after he abolished presidential term
limit so that's a suggestion that any
sort of change to the zero kovi policy
any admittance that this may not be the
entirely correct strategy that is not
going to happen in the short term
anymore and we're going to live with
these sorts of restrictions not just in
shanghai but all over china for many
weeks months to come